Get your NASA-issued
party helmets on,
because it is space week!
Happy Space Week, viewers.
I'm Trace, and you have found
the D News weekly space update.
Space gets people excited.
It's inspiring.
How can you not love the
romantic and exciting ideas
of space travel?
Today begins World Space Week.
The United Nations created
World Space Week in 1999
to commemorate two dates--
October 4 and October 10.
And they use this
time to educate people
about the benefits of
space travel for economies,
for industries, and
get people excited
around the globe about science,
space exploration, and space
education.
On October 4, 1957, the
very first satellite
was launched into
space, Sputnik One.
Think about that.
56 years ago yesterday, nothing
had ever been put into orbit.
Sure, we'd launched
rockets into space.
But that was it.
We had never purposefully
placed anything up there ever.
Sputnik burned up on
reentry a few months later,
but it kicked off the space
race between the Soviet Union
and United States.
October 10, 1967, 10 years after
Sputnik One's successful orbit,
the Treaty on Principles
Governing the Activities
of States in the Exploration and
Peaceful Uses of Outer Space,
Including the Moon and
Other Celestial Bodies
was signed at the
United Nations.
We have actually
referred to it here
at D News as the
Outer Space Treaty.
I think it took 10
years and six days
because they were still
agreeing on that name.
I love this treaty.
It is super interesting.
According to the
Outer Space Treaty,
no country can claim
the moon as its own.
Sorry, America.
And all celestial bodies have
to be used for peace only.
It also mandated that astronauts
were envoys for all mankind,
not just their
country of origin.
If an astronaut somehow
landed in an enemy country,
that country was supposed to
send them home straight away,
though I don't know if
that's ever happened.
Just in case you're
unaware, dollars
spent in space exploration
provide huge benefits
to people on the ground
across the world,
even in nations that
have no space program.
For example, better
digital cameras
were pushed by the Hubble
Space Telescope research.
And that has since made
digital medical devices better.
The jaws of life were
developed for the space program
and now help cut apart
vehicles mangled in car wrecks.
Not to mention satellites for
natural disaster, early warning
systems, community, and
countless other uses.
Space is awesome.
To get into the spirit,
Discovery's online network,
TestTube, is throwing
space celebrations
all across our shows.
Here on D News, we're
going to have a Google
Hangout with some
awesome space nerds.
Nature hates you is going to
tell you why space hates you.
And brain stuff is
getting into the fun too.
So for all the
awesome space video,
check out TestTube.com/space.
So what do you love
about space exploration?
What is your favorite
thing about space programs?
Share your thoughts with
us, and get out there
and enjoy Space Week, everybody.